armes égales barcelo tu vas 31 ans et tu
es devenu en quelques années une des
plus grosses cotes de la peinture
internationale
[Applaudissements]
tu es bien plus important que la movida
de mais tu fais partie d'une génération
d'espagnol fin de peintres espagnols qui
ont dépassé l'après franquisme
c'est à dire que tu n'es plus enfermer
dans mirow dans le nationalisme catalan
dans le repli sur soi c'était tout va
beaucoup plus loin que ça j'espère oui
mais quand même me l'offre saas et de
pentathlon important pour moi c'est
mieux aussi habité justement de majorque
espérons le
alors tu es tu as eu de la chance parce
que ta mère était peintre et quand
j'étais tout petit ami un pinceau dans
les mains très très jeunes étudient j'ai
su très jeune qui était cézanne je crois
je suis en forme mais c'est de me
regarder tranquillement coin ouais c'est
une façon de faire et se trouve quelque
chose aussi d'un majeur quelques
entreprises il y avait beaucoup de
femmes entrepreneurs comme ça viendra
monnaie et tu sortais du moment je vais
directement comme ça c'est certain
intérêt alors ce n'est pas vraiment trop
étrange je prendrais penseurs comme j'ai
eu un sur la familiarité avec les moyens
de traiter je pense que c'est très
important aussi de savoir sa première
exposition c'était à palma oui alors que
je vais me tuer prix des petites boîtes
ah oui dans lesquels tu as d'enfermer
des aventures et puis des matières
organiques c'est des vraies natures
mortes samedi comme ans était venue
cette idée quand même parce que c'est
bizarre quand on est dans quel âge tu
avais quand je fais ça à 17 ans tu
faisais ça c'est à dire je vais
commencer à mettre un terme et de
matériaux organiques pour faire un peu
sort de dégradation notable des musées
qui sont nôtres on peut provoquer une
sorte de vieillissement de la paix
je vais me ranger vos deux avions dash
est en effet un série de portraits
presque avec de la viande
de matériaux organiques qui
pourrissaient s'était enfermé avec un
vert très nette revenant à ses autres
portraits qui alors je viens d'ici en
vitesse fini en trois jours j'ai passé
d'avoir 17 ans je n'aurai à 115 consomme
alors beau jeu de service a appuyé
malheureusement la plupart du monde de
steve m'a pas l'énigme à petit papa
monde et maintenant way est le moment
continental a oui la dérive des
continents
mais bien sûr c'était cette feuille de
la viande sur un grand plan de relance
américain s'était
geoffrey a beaucoup voyagé un peu comme
les étudiants du moyen-âge c'est à dire
que quand tu lisais pessoa tu partais à
lisbonne quand tu voulais étudier
caravage tu partais à naples ensuite est
venue à paris pendant de longues années
pour étudier le louvre qui n'a pas
tellement pour ça me serrer un peu puis
j'ai trouvé caravage oui mais bon il
faudrait justifier que je tenais
c'est pour ça que c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé c'est la tuerie du mali que
c'était les fermes ali ben j'étais
cependant à paris pendant quatre cinq
ans que j'étais à new york et je ne vais
un peu marre de tout ce sont deux
circuits pour un moment je les galeries
tous à 7 s'est énervé mais garde ses
castelli faut le dire comme c'est
castelli à new york c'est lambert à
paris c'est pas les plus mauvais
auspices
oui ça aussi sûrement c'est également
vrai pour ça mais j'ai un peu
l'impression quelques jours c'est sa
tournée là de même sens c'est à dire
qu'ils ont fait c'est chaque année des
exposants des points importants en
occident c'est toujours le même il s'est
énervé ça j'avais envie d'autre chose or
on dit que tu livres projet comme ça
fait partie de ma vie mais la peinture
elle sèche vite au mali quand même
comment tu devrais essayer de trouver
sur la technique un peu spéciale pour
travailler dans une autre façon aussi
parce que les tableaux énorme comme ça
dans de petites maisons de ma vie
c'était presque sais pas je me sentais
pas qu'on va le faire deux saisons c'est
le nombre d'adhérents tous les formats
j'ai trouvé une façon longueur
[Musique]
cette secte a vécu et influencer partie
justement pour toute la grande baroque
de rask la sq et ses compères c'est lui
qui était le plus influencé non mais je
regarde plusieurs beaux costards
cravates commencer quelque chose très
importante des français je regardais
beaucoup cette tradition qui va de
poussan nietzsche ardam manière courbet
j'ai copié beaucoup c'est pareil mais
j'y fais pas trop attention c'est égal
risque il dit ça si je prends ton temps
ça s'est même pas très amusant cette
prend comme un tambour par un tableau
grâce à dernière manhasset beaucoup
c'est à dire depuis en 13 juillet
et j'ai dû faire des tableaux et des
êtres est presque monté alors ça fait 5
t'écoutes quoi quand tu pas pardon tu
écoutes quelle musique quand tu parles
pas n'importe quoi parce que j'ai ce que
tu écoutes pas résumer un lieu pour tuer
la radio je vais appeler n'importe quoi
je n'écoute pas spécialement un groupe
ou une musique ou non après quand je ne
fais pas appel quand j'écoutais
spécialement certaines choses mais pas
quand il ferait s'il devait rester de
toi une définition dans le dictionnaire
de la peinture dorée que ça soit quoi en
une ligne
c'est dur artiste peintre c'est tout je
crois que c'est plutôt drôle comme ça
une complication
ça sert à quoi la peinture pense que ça
sera pas se détendre
puis ça doit peut-être aux autres se
serrent pouvait pas sentir bien mais je
crois que si on pense un sort de forme
de passer le temps les corrections de ne
rien rater le une altitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou